[Music]
and they get to go to their jobs we just
stay home and God that's supposed to be
enough
[Music]
you always want more oh you do candy
whatever you have you always want more
and I'm not gonna apologize for it it is
human nature to take risks to go for
something with a little thrill at the
risk of falling oh you okay
are you sure
[Music]
would you be interested in having an
affair
[Music]
I can never allow Betty or Pat to get
hurt
never I
[Applause]
would love to have you and Pat over
you need to be careful
[Music]
foreign
was murdered by someone she knew did you
kill your wife no
foreign
I did have an affair with Candy
Montgomery
[Music]
no it would not be all right
he just chopped and chopped and chopped
I didn't do it
I think you did you're wrong
it's Texas I hope you might be able to
forgive murder adultery not so much but
Jerry needs to see you as human
and the truth has a way of coming out
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]